foot and mouth disease spreads across
indonesia this has become a familiar
exercise for farmers
this dairy cow is unable to walk or even
stand farmers are taking her to an
abattoir
this disease is frightening first it
hits their mouths with blisters then the
hooves some cannot even walk they just
fall to the ground
the highly contagious spiral disease
causes fevers and painful blisters
infected animals lose their appetite
resulting in dramatic weight loss some
go lame and many die
it's infectious and spread through the
air if one cow is infected in a barn the
others will also be infected soon after
authorities are carrying out a mass
vaccination campaign and vets are
treating livestock with vitamins and
antibiotics
all of these cows are infected with foot
and mouth disease they are dairy cattle
but their milk production has dropped by
more than 70 percent since they became
ill these cows will likely be
slaughtered in coming weeks because
farmers here say they cannot afford to
keep caring for them
most of indonesia's cattle farmers are
smallholders with herds of fewer than
100 animals
these farmers in malang east java say
the outbreak has pushed them into
financial ruin
in my 25 years as a farmer this is the
biggest challenge i've ever faced
the government says it is trying to stop
the disease from spreading both
domestically and overseas
for indonesia especially in the tourist
area like bali
we have the biosecurity restrictions
where people in and out are
have to be screened using the
disinfectant neighbouring australia is
on high alert with estimates its economy
could lose more than 50 billion dollars
over 10 years if foot and mouth disease
reaches its farms
arrivals from indonesia have to undergo
additional screenings in the hope that
scenes like this won't be repeated on
their shores jessica washington al
jazeera bogor west java